hello you all uh my name is andre de
silva i'm the new extension vegetable
specialist um i have talked with you
before during the
vegetable school 2022 about tomato
production about cucurbit
production as well variety selection
fertilizer management irrigation and
today we are switching gears a little
bit and moving to high tunnel uh
vegetable production because i want to
just introduce
what are the challenges for heart tunnel
production what you can grow there and
how can you optimize the land and
increase your profit so
if you are a small grower or a home
garden
high tunnel is a very good um
it's a very good approach for you to
increase the value of your produce per
area because you can produce sometimes
that
open field cannot do that and if you are
a hot um
bigger grower i saw that there from the
from the quick survey that they did in
the beginning there are one or two uh
large growers here with 20 to 50 acres
that's also a good opportunity for you
like to provide uh produce or to have
produced for like big contracts or even
farm markets in a time of the year that
it's like not very common for example
lettuce
early during the winter or tomato or the
spring so
if you have gone to some grocery stores
you have seen that the price of tomato
increase and that's because there's a
shorter shortage in the market so if you
have a high tuner you can
be able to sell your produce at those
high high prices so that's what you
would be looking for if you're doing a
high tunnel uh if you want to install a
hydronium so this is going to be a very
interrogatory one uh so feel free to
make question if you have a particular
question how to do some specific things
like oh what fertilizer or how much
water to apply or feel free to make a
question but first i want to
start talking about what is a high tuna
i don't know if you guys are familiar
but a high tuna has the same green is
the same structure as a greenhouse
so it can be um
of lumber it can be of
aluminium um just one quick thing if you
are doing for organic
area uh lumber should not be treated
while if you have aluminium uh you don't
have any problem
it's you usually cover with one layer of
six mil film
and uh it allows for uh solar heat and
uh wind coolant so you can allow for
ventilation there because you can
manually open
uh
the sides of your tunnel like you see
here we have sides or here in the door
we can open the door so this is a
recently new height you know actually we
finished building these two high tunnels
last friday so those two high tunnels
are in our organic farm in shelton in
the uvsmith so if you guys want to visit
and see how it's a brand new high tunnel
that's a good opportunity in an organic
field
and we can
manage them as we want usually high
tunnels can go from 10 feet
by
up to
96 like 10 feet off we did like here we
have a 32 feet one and can
from 10 to 32 wide and uh
it can go
up to 96 foot long so this is what
you're gonna be uh dealing with so if
you have a smaller operation so you can
go with a 10 feet or a 20 feet you just
need to find what is the best specs
that's gonna allow you for um
for that's gonna allow for your area of
production so this is a brand new one
like i said that we can open the side so
allow for ventilation so during the
summer when used to well like when
you're gonna have like higher
temperatures you can open the sides and
allow for ventilation to don't let like
stress your plants with heat
uh those high tunnels they can be
permanent which is the most common one
but nowadays you have those that are
mobile
one and then you can move from one
location to another i will not get in
depth about those that can be moved i
will focus on the permanent one because
like 99.9 of the production we have in
the state is going to be with permanent
one and here i just put a quick um
a quick uh price per square feet and
that's how you're gonna buy it you can
get it from like many uh vendors
and uh
they are very uh practical first
installation or you can build your own
but why i'm talking about to use those
high tuna because high tunnels have five
points of benefits that i want to talk
today and that's going to be the focus
of my uh our conversation
so
the first one is because high 2 they can
extend growing season what is it means
we can plant like a particular crop
early
early in the season or we can plant when
it's in the spring or we can plant a
particular crop later in the fall so
that's the benefits and that's what i
want to talk also it can mitigate risks
associated to weather like we we're
going to talk a little bit later about
like the cold this frost that we just
got this past weekend or we can talk
about heavy rainfall events so that's
some of the benefits of itunes it can
also reduce pest pressure
and we're going to talk about the
permanent plastic exclusion season dr a
has a very strong program on how to
install those uh
exclusion system and he would be a good
person for you guys to approach in
consideration for like how to avoid
insects on
on high tuning finally how to manage
those high tuners to enhance crop yield
and how you can get a higher quality and
as the last one i want to talk i just
want to come back for how marketing
uh
and what is the
advantage of a high tuner on you to
market your produce so that's how we're
going to be talking today
so first of all
uh we're going to talk about extending
growing scenes
so here i put a
greek graphic that is an aces
publications from dr campbell on how
when to grow vegetable crops in alabama
and we have for all most of our common
vegetable crops here that can also be
grown in alabama so those are for open
field on high tunnels you can get up to
60 days
of early season so just thinking about
why a grower can you a open field grower
can be will be harvesting their bell
peppers in june july and august a high
tunnel grower could be harvesting may
and april when there is no market
when there is no bell pepper in the
market so that's when you can have your
higher price so i just emphasized here
in this sentence that a well-managed
high tuning growing seed growing system
utilizing plastic mulching
with raised bed mulching fume and broke
overs can length the growing seas
season it's a frost in a frosty period
which would be when the grower of the
high tunnel would be planting their bell
pepper or whatever solanaceae
by as much as 60 days so that's the
first advantage i just show you examples
with the bell pepper but the same can be
uh protected by cabbage which is a cool
crop which we usually harvest in october
for the fall season or in april and may
for the winter for the spring season
with a high to no cabbage in a high tuna
you can harvest it in december or you
can harvest it in january so you don't
have that impact of the frost that we
usually do have in uh during the winter
so those are the kind of advantages that
uh
a high tunu
can provide for a grower
so
but to do that you need to be careful
you need to prepare your planting dates
you need to be like
you need to keep track of your planting
dates your variety selections when to
plant and how to do the crop succession
because you don't want to plant the same
crop in the same location to avoid
problems with disease and you don't want
uh to
plant everything in the same day because
you need to support a market so you want
to do different planting dates in order
in order to provide that um to supply
that market with your produce so keep
that in mind
playing with planting dates and crop
succession it's an important thing for
on a high tuna production
and how it can mitigate risks associated
with the weather like i said before we
can have frost protection here is a
common temperature of the this graph
here shows a common
movement of uh high temperature in uh
high maximum temperature in red uh
minimum temperature in blue or how we
have during the spring early season as
we have january and then
all the way to the end of the season so
you need to see when you are planting
and what is the weather conditions for
that because when you have it
outside temperatures
of uh
the outside temperature is completely
different from the the temperature
inside the high tunnel so that's what
you need to understand in order to
optimize your production and select the
right planting dates
one good thing off of high tunnel you
don't have wind damage you don't have a
directly sun exposure or you can even
cover your high tunnels with some shades
so you can grow during the summer and
also you don't have the direct impact of
rainfall events that you can like soak
your field
and though all those problems frost wind
damage directly sun explosion and
rainfall events can cause some of the
common uh disorder in produced like i
talked in my first class on tomato
production like sunny scouting in
tomatoes or cracking because of rainfall
events and the wrapped growth of
tomatoes or even you can have some hails
on by wings or
other problems in your tomato so those
are the advantage of the tomato it's of
the the high tunas it's gonna
allow you to produce a high quality and
reduce the problems with cools when you
are harvesting your uh produce
we had a very good example like i said
in the beginning this past week
for a
uh
for the frost protection so this is just
a graph where we have friday march 11th
saturday march 12
march 13 march 14 march 15 which is
today during this weekend and this is
the weather for central alabama i got
this from the
a little bit for a weather station a
little bit north of uh montgomery so
just for you to see
on high tunnel production
the green area here represent optimum
temperatures of outside for high tunnel
production while the red it's going to
be too low for high to no production so
imagine if you for food production sorry
so
imagine if you are a grower who thought
that we already had our last our last uh
frost of the year back in
february and you put your watermelons in
the field you put your tomato in the
field
but then you suddenly had that lower
temperatures on saturday or even sunday
where it's got lows of 27.
so that's temperature will definitely
kill your plants
so but if you had a high tuna that would
not be the case you would have a
reduction in growth
which would delay your season but it
will not kill your plants so that's a
benefit of having a high tunnel you
don't have those problems with weather
conditions that are very common on open
field
another topic that i'm going to go with
very quick on high tunnels is uh that
while the weather is
something beneficial
insect disease and weeds are also
easier to control however keep in mind
if you don't do a proper integrated path
management and that's what dr sakura
will be talking later
you're gonna have a quick infestation
for example
these three white flies here in this
leaf can quickly become a high
population in a high tunnel because they
have all favorable conditions to
reproduce in a high tunnel it's a close
environment rainfall cannot knock then
then down and they can quickly spread
they can also quickly grow aphids there
from a small one they can also be large
aphids and they can start to transmit
disease and that's what dr sakota will
be talking later about the disease
problems but see white flies can
transmit crampon virus so it can quickly
destroy or
outbreak your height you know production
if not properly managed or you can have
even other disease um
for tomatoes if you don't like have soil
borne disease there
you will not be able to plant tomato for
a while
if you have problems there so the
management of disease and also weeds and
insects in high tunnel must to be
quickly managed
otherwise you're gonna have that area
infested and over us one season to
another you will be losing a lot of
youth potential so here is just some
example of
some goose grass that can go this is an
open field that we have but in a high
tunnel it's going to be very similar it
can quickly spread in the field and we
can uh even see
more high tunnels so my recommendation
is if you are growing in a high tuna
and you will not
plant in the summer because you are
achieving highest yield in your market
during early spring and late fall
don't go to the beach and leave your
heart to no unattended
please go ahead plant a cover crop try
to manage problems that you have during
the season with a cover crop or with any
other uh practice like solarization or
any other um
cash crop during the summer otherwise
you're gonna start to having more
problems
we're gonna come back and talk a little
bit more about that but i would like to
give one of good examples that dr a
usually talked on about the past
exclusion because he has some permanent
exclusion system to prevent uh
the past establishment like the use of
shade plus is a low-cost option and
easily available for the growers so here
is an example from dr a where we install
it he install it in a growers field like
this uh shade cloud is net that will not
allow insects to enter in the high
tunnel so that's why we say that is a
permanent exclusion system is gonna be
all the time there it is to allow air
movement
and most important it will avoid insects
to get into your
system
this is a particular photo that i really
like from uh dr a because we have like
we can see
insects trying to get into the high
tunnel but our um
exclusion system is
working the way how it was supposed to
be so that's one of the way that because
you can open your sides allow air um
to ventilation and still protect it from
your from insects
so switching gear from the
ipm program that we still going to talk
later i want to talk about
give you guys some options of how you
can increa enhance your crop yield and
your crop yield potential and your
quality in high tunnel
you want to plant high value crops
you
have a high investment to build that
high tuna or to purchase that high
tunnel and you want to make that
investment worth
so select crops that you're going to
have higher yields or i mean higher
value so tomato cucumber spinach pepper
strawberry strawberry
summer squash lettuce and even cut cut
flowers are good options for uh
for high tunnel production i just put
some photos here that we have
from from some of the high tuners uh
that we have played tried before and to
show you that like those can all all of
those crops can be produced in high
tunnels in the state of alabama
but to do that you need to do a quick
three steps so going let's say you
decide to plant on your high tuna you
decide to move forward and yes we're
gonna do a high tunnel once you do a
high tunnel you select your crop but now
follow three steps in order for you to
maximize your production and don't have
problems first step is do a crop
rotation here we have a quick line of
what crops should be success succeed by
the other ones so let's go for a four
step crop rotation plant we have first
we grow we we grow our leaf green
in area one and then in the same area
which is the same high tuna we go with a
fruit a tomato a bell pepper
next season we're going to do some root
we can plant some carrots we can plant
some potatoes there try to diversify and
then later you come with a legume plant
some beans there plant some uh dried in
there so this way you can maximize your
ear and next and in the next season you
come for again with greens this will
minimize your problems with disease with
insects
okay so that's a good operation or a
crop rotation that your operation should
have in order to maximize yield
once you select your crop you build your
you created your plan of crop rotation
then you're going to talk about
irrigation and fertilizer management in
high tunnel
i will not go in that crop by crop that
should be uh the fertilization of
the crop by crop fertilization program
i'm gonna say follow the fertilizer
recommendation and use soil samples we
have the vegetable book the vegetable
handbook we have the
high tuna uh
vegetable handbook so you guys have all
this information on hand if you don't
find it contact your uh your agent they
can they can contact us or you can
contact us directly and we're gonna help
you with that but one thing that i would
like to emphasize on the fertilizer end
is nowadays the price of fertilizer is
just increasing so consider use compost
and manure that's not a problem our
currently recommendation for goals from
120 to 400 gallons per 100 square feet
in high tunnel production and do that
about 120 days
before harvesting your crop follow the
food safety is important in high tunnel
production as well because you cannot
apply raw manure
before if you are harvesting your crop
in 120 days so apply it before that
otherwise if this is raw manure if you
have a composite manure or a treated
manure then you are good but if not do
if it's a raw manure 120 days before
harvesting and i would recommend you
guys to apply this
uh
this uh
manure or this compost before planting
in advance so you can allow it for uh
nutrients to be available and follow up
with some liquid fertilization that's
important for you to supply nutrients in
the middle of the season don't only
apply it pre-plant and think that oh
we're gonna be all fine remember
if you have like
high temperatures you're gonna have
mineralization of your nitrogen there
you're gonna have maybe that nitrogen
will not be available for your uh
for your crop most importantly a lot of
compost they are high in phosphorus and
then if they have high temperature that
phosphorus will uh
not other nutrients and will not allow
plants to uptake other nutrients so
don't rely only in a high application of
compost and manure it's a very good
approach to use manure i would strongly
recommend however follow with
other fertilization don't only apply the
manure
and
fertilizer or nutrients are linked in a
way with irrigation that if you change
one you're going to affect the other so
irrigation is another key important
aspect in a height to you mostly because
when you have a high tunnel you are
change the environment of your crop you
have higher temperatures that will
enhance your plant growth but those
plant growth that those higher are
faster growth also require more water
for your plants so irrigation management
becomes important in the high tunnel so
there are two things when we talk about
irrigation management first is what
system to use the most common ones are
drip and sprinkler irrigation however i
would say say no for sprinkler
irrigation
because you want to apply water
in the soil not in the plant if you
apply water in the plant you are create
optimal conditions for disease to get
into your plants and that's going to be
a problem so prioritize drip irrigation
if drip is not okay it's not feasible
for your operation then it's okay to go
with sprinkler or with an overhead
irrigation and most of the growers think
that oh
uh sprinkler irrigation is a single um
a single uh investment while drip we
need to change every year
yes that's true however the likelihood
for you to fail with a sprinkler is much
higher than with a drip irrigation or
you're gonna need to have a higher
investment in uh disease and pest
control with a sprinkler when compared
with a drip also sprinkle require more
water consumption than a drip
consequently you're gonna have more cost
with pumping that water
more water also is required so
because of all that factors i strongly
recommend our growers to install drip
irrigation in their
high tunnels that they're gonna they're
gonna see a considerable uh increase in
yield and reduction in inputs
once the the irrigation system is
determined i would go with the
irrigation scan if you have seen my
talks about irrigation scheduling i
usually recommend
three types of scheduling in alabama for
open field which is the systematic the
crop evapotranspiration and soil
moisture sensors but that's for open
field in high tunnel i would recommend
or you do the systematic irrigation
which requires a irrigation panel in
your high tunnel and you're going to
apply the same volume of water every day
or you're going to run your system at
the same time or you're going to use the
soil moisture sensors where you're going
to apply water according to your soil
your soil water availability the reason
why i don't recommend the crop water
demand or using evapotranspiration is
because the environmental conditions
within a high tunnel is different than
outdoor so you will not be able to
provide
you will not be able to s like to
estimate how much water is being lost by
your plant
so using the soil moisture sensors are
currently the best approach for high
tunnels in irrigation scan systematics
are okay however you also is applying
you are applying water by feeding you
think that your your plants need that
that volume of water which might be
not true so if you are a very
experienced uh
high tuna grower your uh the systematic
irrigation or using a panel to apply the
same volume every day it's probably
going to be a good option however if you
are not if you are new i would strongly
recommend soi moisture sensors and if
from those experience one using sensors
they're going to see that they have a
much better return and an increase in
their use
so
once you are finished with step two i
will move for step three which is the
pest management know your disease know
your insects know your weeds we have all
the publications available for you to
identify that
know it in advance for your crop because
like i said a disease a insect can
quickly spread in your high tunnel for
disease do a good cultivar selection
select coachbars that are resistant for
particular disease in your area and
you're going to do always a preventive
management which means you don't want to
see the disease there you want to first
up you want to first
apply products and that will not allow
the disease to grow in your area or use
cultivars that are resistant for that
disease while insect use the permanent
exclusion system insects it's more like
you control it as you see there
so
frequent scoutings of your high tuners
are very important while the weed
management you're gonna be doing the
scouting for the insect and you need to
do that some problems that you have that
you're gonna have in alabama with uh
weeds in our
high tunnel will be nutsed will be
morning glory and those are like uh
pigweed and those are those
weeds that are very common also outdoor
so follow those um
know what you're gonna be dealing with
so this way you can be like more in
quickly on the prevention or on the
management of these pests so do those
three steps and you're gonna be able to
see some increase on your yield this is
a data that a group of um
in the southeast put together for how
much yield can be increased in high
tunnel production when compared to open
field so just take a look on the
cucumber while you can you can yield
point half pound half pound per square
feet in the open field in a high tunnel
you can double it
and look at this spinach you can have
like almost six or nine times ten times
almost nine eight times more on spinach
production bell pepper five times more
tomato you can increase four times more
so just see how better how higher is
your yield if you do a good crop
management in your high tunnel so those
are the benefits of the heightening if
you do a good crop management you
consequently will have a higher yield
than in an open field and you're going
to be adding value to that product
because high tunnel is much easier for
you
to a management than open field even for
organic so if you are doing a high
tunnel i would strongly recommend try to
certify that high tuning if you certify
that high tunnel for organic production
that's going to be a good approach for
you to even increase your profit per
area
so those are all the benefits that a
high tuna have and when we are talking
about marketing that i said that would
be my last topic i would come back for
those planting dates that i talked in
the beginning of my um of these
presentations so you are looking for
off-season windows remember bell pepper
you don't want to harvest bell pepper of
a high tuna in june you want to harvest
that before june or after november
so that's when you have your best winter
same thing that we talked about cabbage
and now and
and like that and you go on for every
single crop do a succession of crops and
planting days try to diversify your
production and finally add value for
your product conventional versus organic
hype tuna versus on open field this way
you're gonna have a higher profit and
optimize the use of your high tune so
just to summarize a little bit the
importance of height of of uh to the
take-home message from this uh
this presentation today keep in mind
that high tunnel they do have an extreme
potential and they can be done in
alabama in the entire state however it
does require an investment
it is an upfront investment that you
should be considering
when you select uh when you have your
high tunnel selecting the high value
crops can help this pain back but
remember you need to do your crop
management and your high tunnel
maintenance this is key for you to
maintain that high tunnel for a long
time and you don't need to do more
investment or rebuild a high tunnel and
finally playing with your marked
marketing is fundamental play with your
plan date succession of plans and if you
need any of these information
at the alabama extension uh at the aces
we have a high tunnel crop production
book that now is available um
i believe we are releasing the second
edition of this high tunnel crop
production handbook and it's gonna be
available uh online and you can download
that and even read from your cell phone
so those are all informations that you
have available and if you still have any
question you can contact me or contact
our agent we can come together with a
plan to help with any problem
and let me know if you guys have any
questions
you